[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct c'est
figaro lag et on attend donc vos points
de vue en particulier sur les menaces
qui pèsent sur le déconfinement faut-il
absolument descendre au seuil des 5000
contaminé fixé par emmanuel macron le 14
octobre dernier on va en débattre avec
vous vous nous donnez vos points de vue
et on va en débattre avec philippe meyer
bonsoir philippe le physique mais hier
c'est votre pseudo sur twitter je n'ai
rien 453 en france alors il fallait que
je remette un exactement et votre oeuvre
en mode majeur c'est le noël esprit
public qui est en campagne de
financement
c'est un podcast pour reprendre votre
formule et je signale le dernier épisode
sur les défis rencontrés par vladimir
poutine dans son étranger proche en
particulier notamment en arménie mais
également biélorussie avec la
biélorussie est aussi la plus d'un débat
très passionnant sur la restriction des
libertés
ça c'est en première partie podcast vous
allez en débattre d'ailleurs peut-être
avec alexis brezet ce soir directeur des
rédactions du figaro bonsoir l'exemple
alors le figaro revient dans les
prochaines heures sur l'a notamment sur
la loi sur les principes républicains
exploit séparatisme ex la laïcité
dorénavant loi sur les principes du
kansas qu'elle change de nom vous pensez
pas que ça va être même le nom va paître
on parle aussi du on va parler aussi je
pense dans le quotidien du bureau de la
sécurité
la proposition d' emmanuel macron et
donc effectivement on en parle on en
débat ce soir et ce sera en deuxième
partie mais d'abord cette question sera
ton des confiné dans une semaine on y
croyait et puis on a eu un doute
hier en écoutant en entendant le
professeur jérôme salle au monde
chaque jour plus de dix mille nouvelles
personnes sont testées positives contre
5000 par semaine au corps au coeur de
l'été
nous devons être vigilants devant cette
évolution récente mais nous sommes
encore loin de l'objectif de passer sous
la barre des 5000 cas par jour
alors faut-il maintenir ce seuil des
5000 cas parking par jour c'est la
question qu'on vous pose d'ailleurs sur
sur twitter
et je vous propose d'écouter cet égard
le point de vue du député républicain
l'est républicain sébastien huyghe
attention c'est court ça se finit en
l'air le problème c'est que nos
compatriotes commence à être exaspérés
par la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes
je pense que ce serait une erreur de
resserrer l'étau
ce serait une erreur de resserrer l'étau
ne dit sébastien hui votre point de vue
alexi je suis plutôt d'accord avec lui
d'abord il faut voir la situation et la
gravité ou pas de la situation
comment dire d'abord je moi qui suis
honnête citoyen je me réfère
l'application officielle officiel de
monsieur salomon il nous dit que dix
mille cas ben arfa tard son application
dana 3411 hier à 13 heures alors si
jamais le bon jour il ya toujours un
décalage quelque chose qui va pas vous
faire 3411 c'est pas dix mille c'est bon
non craignent en dessous de 5 me par
ailleurs cette affaire de 5000 il faut
bien voir d'où ça vient c'est ok mais un
maquereau qu'il ya quinze jours nous
annonce à lui il installe deux critères
le critère des 5000 pour les pour les
contaminations et les critères entre
2500 et 3000 en réanimation
le deuxième critère où ce mot critères
on est bon on sera en dessous des 3000
donc ça ça va le premier critère 5000 il
semblerait qu'on ne soit pas bon après
douceur ce 5000 c'est pas un chiffre
médical n'a pas de réalité scientifique
s'est pas battu deux cent mille en tout
5000 c'est pas plus ou moins graves
c'est simplement que le raisonnement qui
a été fait c'est de dire à partir de
5000 cas on serait capables nous dit-on
prétendons de traquer les autres assez
isolé
protéger le trac enfin bon le truc qu'on
n'a pas des super six a été tracé et les
vois le truc qu'on n'a pas fait du tout
pendant l'été ce qui n'a pas du tout
marché bon maintenant nous prétend que
le jour on aura plus que 5000 on saura
le faire je n'en crois pas un mot mais
donc en fait cette affaire de 5000 que
sur cinq ou six mille je ne vois pas
bien où cette mine même ça me paraît pas
une immense différence
en revanche dire aux gens qui vont voir
partir en vacances pour noël qui vont
pas les voir leurs familles qui n'ont
pas les voir leurs grands mères qui
n'ont pas les voir leurs dents petits
enfants me paraît très catastrophique et
ne serait pas supporter donc ils ne le
font pas ils ne feront pas philippe
parce que vous êtes partagés le
pronostic d'alexis et est-ce qu'on
laisse les français en liberté où on
privilégie la sécurité la sécurité
sanitaire
cette question a déjà reçu sa réponse en
dont l'idée de laisser les français se
débrouiller tout seul est une idée qui
était peut-être viable et qui maintenant
a sérieusement du plomb dans l aile suis
pas d'accord avec ce que dit monsieur
hui exaspéré je pense que ça s'applique
à certaines personnes et notamment à
celles qui ont le plus à souffrir
directement
je pense aux cafetiers aux restaurateurs
pour qui c'est une catastrophe
considérable sans compter qu'en plus je
crois d'ailleurs c'est vous qui l'avez
publié dans le figaro
beaucoup d'entre eux ne touchent pas les
aides qui leur sont promises et donc je
pense que plus ce qui exaspérait on est
perdu on est perdus parce que trop de
gens parlent parce que parmi les trop de
gens qui parlent
il ya trop d'idiot et l'idiot bavard
l'idiot bavard qui a décidé qu'il
fallait mettre ses parents ses
grands-parents au pardon dans la cuisine
pour manger le reste leur part de la
bûche et chef de service à l'hôpital
necker il est chef de service à la pizza
le président de la commission médicale
de l'assistance-publique-hôpitaux pas je
ne doute pas du tout ses qualités
médicale parce que je n'ai aucune espèce
de capacité pour les juger mais comme
citoyen et comme observateur de la vie
publique des affaires publiques comme
disent les québécois
ce propos est un propos idiots il y en a
eu d'autres y compris dans la bouche
confrères ce que je veux dire c'est
surtout qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
tiennent ce genre de propos celui là est
le plus fleuri et
de ceux qui sont dans les derniers en
date y en a beaucoup d'autres il avait
trouvé de marseille jusque jusqu'à l'île
à propos de l'île d'ailleurs je fais une
parenthèse un moment donné on nous a dit
l'institut pasteur avait trouvé qu'un
médicament qui existaient pouvait avoir
des effets positifs de lutte contre le
virus qu'un médicament c'est très
intéressant peut-être plus dans un
premier temps qu'un vaccin parce que les
vaccins soient les produire et puis
beaucoup de choses sont encore comme le
dit le monsieur vaccin professeur fisher
beaucoup de choses sont encore inconnues
beaucoup d'effets sont encore inconnues
ce truc a disparu complètement et on ne
sait absolument pas ce qu'il en est de
ses trouvailles de l'institut pasteur
qui disait un emploi vous dire le nom
peux pas vous dire le nom parce que tout
le monde se précipiteraient dessus pas
très bien là dessus donc je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup plus de gens désorientés que
de gens exaspérés ce qui n'est pas moins
grave
ce qui n'est pas moins grave parce que
dans cette espèce de situation qui est
presque anomique à l'intérieur c'est ça
le paradoxe est que un maximum de loin
on l'a dit je ne sais combien de fois
pour l'impôt trop d'impôt tué l'impôt
trop de réglementations tu la
réglementation et à l'intérieur de sa
faute de voir des critères qu'ils soient
des critères clairs chacun bricole c'est
le système d du comportement et se dit
bon allez on dit si sa table mais on
sera à 8
allez on sera à 8 et puis bon la cuisine
est trop petit pour mettre les
grands-parents donc on va les garder
c'est ça qui me gêne le plus parce que
les 5000 pour dire un mot si j'ai bien
compris et là encore je veux pas ajouter
une bêtise à celle dont je viens de dire
qu'elle était trop nombreuse sur les
antennes et dans l'air dans les journaux
sur le si j'ai bien compris les 5000
c'est une question plateau c'est à dire
que si on reste au même plateau qui soit
7,5 ou 3 on n'a pas de marge de
manoeuvre est donc on ne peut pas se
débrouiller pour gérer cette affaire
mais c'est pas comme ça que ça a été
expliqué ça a été expliquée comme ça par
un médecin que j'ai entendues dont je ne
sais pas s'il est sa parole doit être
tenu pour parole d'évangile
mais c'est sûrement pas comme ça que ça
a été expliquée et on nous dit 5000 et
maintenant nous savons qu'on n'aura pas
les 5000 et qu'en plus il y a pour
répondre enfin votre question vincent
il y a depuis j'ai désespérément depuis
les 2 5 km celui du canada et celui des
etats unis
on a toutes les raisons d'avoir la plus
grande peur que ça reparte à noël alors
est ce que justement avec les
informations qui viennent des états unis
et
du canada est ce que vous craignez pas
que justement il ya une annonce la
semaine prochaine qui disent qu'ils
maintiennent les restrictions ils vont
maintenir un peu ils vont à mon sens il
faut ouvrir un peu moins que prévu ou
fermés un petit peu plus que prévu donc
ils vont dire que oui on se stoppe le
confinement mais il ya un couvre-feu
mais le couvre feu sera peut-être plus
tôt que ce qu'on disait que peut-être
les cinémas les théâtres
je doute qu'il renonce à les ouvrir
totalement mais peut-être qu'ils vont
dire que les jauges au lieu d'être
établi à une la moitié de la salle
seront établis un tiers de la salle on a
retrouvé quelque chose je pense qu'un
des objectifs qui me paraît justifié
nécessaire du point de vue de la deûle à
l'esprit public ces de c2c de laisser
une fiche la paix aux gens au moins noël
on peut pas indéfiniment embêter les
gens avec une situation qu'on ne
maîtrise pas qu'on ne comprend pas
absolument pas ce que 5 skyrim je veux
bien mais en ce moment il ya plein
d'enfants salaire de repartir en fait
cette épidémie on ne sait jamais très
bien pourquoi elle s'arrête su alors on
va le les cobras ont commencé à baisser
avant le début confinement on sait pas
très bien pourquoi et même avant le
début du couvre feu dans certains
endroits où il n'y avait pas de course
mais s'abaissait salaire là on arrive à
un plateau qui n'est pas absolument
étonnant c'est à dire que tout ça c'est
des coupes logarithmique parce qu'en
maintenant en même temps que mon
expérience métier lundi un expert
mathématiques appris ce que c'était une
combe logarithmique sa part tout
doucement souvent ça montrait très très
très très vite et quand ça descend ça
descend très très très très très vite et
après ça ça va tout doucement donc on en
est à la phase 6 est tout doucement pour
il semblerait qu'elle soit un peu trop
plate cette phase de toulouse ne s'est
pas non plus absolument invraisemblable
et il semblerait que dans plusieurs pays
d'europe qui ne sont pas dans la
situation du point de vue du couvre feu
du confinement de ceci de cela les mêmes
évolutions se produisent sans qu'on
sache très bien pourquoi peut-être que
tout bêtement c'est la température c'est
aussi ce qu'on dit donc je pense que il
ya quand même beaucoup de mystères qui
échappe à nos gouvernants donc s'ils
pouvaient nous épargner un tout petit
peu pour le labradoodle et puis s'il
faudra refaire mais après de toute façon
faudra fermer après la question qui est
posée en ce moment sur twitter et
youtube faut-il revoir le seuil des 5000
nouveaux cas par jour fixé par le
gouvernement pour le déconfinement sur
youtube par exemple vous répondez oui à
75% comme babineau le seuil des 5000 cas
annoncés par la mairie de macron est
plutôt arbitraire il faut sortir du
principe de précaution pendant les fêtes
c'est votre point de vue également
inquiété de ne pas avoir de nouvelles de
l'avant le salut renom mais ce jeu
revient sur le truc de thanksgiving
en réalité la cour avait déjà commencé à
monter avant thanksgiving mais elle a
monté un peu plus on enseigne gearing
qui me semble c'est juste une espèce
d'outils pédagogiques d'outils de
communication pour dire aux gens on
voyait chez les autres donc fait
attention mais si c'était possible dans
parce que on voit bien que on sait peu
de choses
et après tout on peut pas reprocher aux
gens notamment aux gouvernants de savoir
peu de choses sur quelque chose qui ne
s'est jamais produit mais au moins si
c'était possible de faire en sorte que
le moins d'autorité gouvernementale
s'exprime que y ait un ou deux porte
parole du gouvernement des positions du
gouvernement un ou deux pédagogues du
gouvernement sur ces questions
et puis que le président se réservent
les grandes orientations pas qu'ils nous
expliquent combien on peut être à table
il ya quelque chose je sais bien que la
comparaison est facile elle est de
mauvaise foi pour faire vous imaginez le
général de gaulle dix ans et pour noël
ouais c'est ça c'est pas la même période
d'accord je t'offre le plaisir de cette
caricature mais le quart est calculée
d'un droit est un droit sacré mais c'est
ça moi que j'attends le plus après le
chiffre de 5000
il est sûrement arbitraire c'est
incontestable et 7250 ça ferait
peut-être plus scientifique mais ce
serait tout aussi arbitraire et 3 milles
séparaient donc c'est pas le chiffre
c'est vrai qu'on était à 50 milles il ya
pas si longtemps sa veste
tombé très très très très vite de 50000
à mam il manie le fameux est redescendu
le 1er et le r il ya cinq ans il est à 0
58 à 0 50% à 8 016 personnes donc
mathématiquement à chaque génération de
la maladie sa baisse de moitié
donc faut pas non plus faut pas que ça à
peine 1 voila voila c'est à dire mais là
on est très en dessous de 20 0 58 et ce
sont les statistiques de monsieur
salomon donc pas nous reprocher cela
vous avez la chance d'entendre des
statistiques de monsieur salon les
imitations du général de gaulle vous
avez raison d'être sur figaro life ce
soir justement christophe nous dit ça
peut être un mot sur justement de la
culture si j'ai bien compris on sera
privé de cinéma à partir du 15 décembre
alors la continuation c'est que
normalement de les rouvrir on verra moi
mon pronostic c'est plutôt qu'on va mais
peut-être que je me trompe pas je n'en
sais rien peut-être mais montrait plutôt
qu'on va les rouvrir mais avec une jauge
plus
des passionnés de théâtre et cinéma il
ya une bonne chance pour qu'il soit
soumis à d'autres contraintes horaires
mais qui puisse ouvrir et une aux
nettement c'est aussi une façon soulagé
au cinéma noël les gens qui ne vont
jamais au cinéma il veut à noël après
avoir acheté le prix goncourt qui ne
verront pas sur ça c'est un pronostic
signé philippe meyer ses parents ce
statut peut être une autre chose sur un
propose que de ce que disait philippe
tout à leur dit qu'ils n'étaient pas
d'accord que sébastien huyghe quand il
disait les français sont exaspérés il
surtout ils les français sont perdus
vous votre point de vue sur alexis
renvoyant toutes les achaque fois qu'on
pose des questions est-ce qu'il ya pas
plutôt une vraie séparation entre d'un
parent d'un côté des français qui sont
exaspérés par la situation de l'eau ali
solarisation mois ci sont quelque chose
qui me frappe c'est à dire que j'ai
quand même le sentiment que dans ce
domaine comme dans beaucoup d'autres on
a des polarisations d'opinion entre d'un
côté des gens qui sont toujours aussi
prudent qu'au début et toujours aussi
partisan de mesures de fermeture de
précaution est toujours plus et
peut-être une france souvent qui
d'ailleurs plus âgé parce qu'ils
s'estiment donc pour ces raisons plus à
risque et puis une france qui est plus
jeune plus actifs qui elle évolue vers a
un côté on en a marre maintenant
finalement il n'ya pas tant de gens qui
meurent de toute façon les hôpitaux
aujourd'hui ne sont plus bien ce qui est
vrai
le principal c'est de ne ne pas engorger
les hôpitaux mais pour l'instant ils ne
le sont pas et donc on sent que moi ce
que je veux en tout cas c'est donc dans
les questionnaires qu'on fait sur le fil
au figaro où pendant des mois et
notamment lors du brier confinement
c'était d'une écrasante limité de 80 90
% toujours toujours toujours pour les
mesures plus une mesure était de
précaution plus elle été plébiscité j'ai
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que de
plus en plus on a des poux partage 50/50
60 40 40 60 qui prouve que les gens une
partie des français qui était absolument
à qui est cette mesure de précaution
commences à te dire maintenant ça va
bien je pense qu'il faut ajouter aussi
certains lieux
et puis je pense plus particulièrement
au département de la seine saint denis
au fameux 9 3 dans lequel le confinement
ne se vit pas du tout de la même manière
que dans beaucoup d endroits là je parle
pas je veux pas une comparaison avec
l'avenue foch ou avec avec le 16e ou 17e
arrondissement mais simplement il ya
dans cet endroit des conditions de vie
dans ce département il ya des conditions
de vie qui sont plus difficiles qui
angle confinement plus difficile qui en
acceptation du confinement plus
difficile et puis aussi il faut bien
dire que ce sont des endroits dans
lequel l'autorité n'est pas ce qui est
le plus facilement reconnu par toute une
partie de la population pour de
mauvaises et pour de bonnes raisons
aussi
et j'ajouterai que les jeunes qu'ils
soient de ce niveau du 16e
arrondissement en ont par-dessus la tête
de toutes ces contraintes considèrent
souvent à juste titre qu'ils ne courent
aucun risque que des facteurs qui l'ont
déjà tous plus ou moins un but
il mena ne pense qu'à une chose c'est
faire la fête sortir voir leurs amis et
très franchement on ne peut pas
absolument leur reprocher de ne pas se
contenter indéfiniment de cette vie de
reclus où ils ne vont pas en val
universités pas au lycée ils voient plus
d'amis ils vont plus dans les bars et
rompraient ils en ont ras-le-bol
ça n'a aucun sens peut-être un dernier
commentaire autour de ce que nous dit
paul sur youtube ça n'a aucun sens de
prendre seulement en compte le nombre de
cas on pourrait prendre peut-être le
nombre de cas par test par exemple c'est
vrai que le nombre de cas dépend
étroitement du nombre de tests et dans
seulement du nombre de tests de la façon
dont remonte les résultats des tests
parce que là il ya toute une polémique
très compliqué sur les nouveaux tests
antigénique alors certains disent il ya
de plus en plus de tests parce qu'elle
était senti génique donc c'est normal
qu'ils aient plus de cadres d'autres
disent oui mais il ya de plus en
proportion est de plus en plus de tester
génique antigénique pendant les états ne
remonte pas ne sont pas agglomérées donc
en fait il y aurait encore plus de cas
que ce qu'on nous dit tout ça est
extrêmement dépendante de la façon dont
on récolte les cavs il ajouté à ça que
des gens comme elon musk eux se font
tester quatre fois le même jour deux
fois ils sont positifs et deux fois ils
sont négatifs alors ils décident qu'il
va rester sur le positif parce qu'il
veut mettre personne en danger
enfin au milieu de tout ça quand je
disais tout à l'heure qu'on à faire du
bien on est perdu on est perdus d'où la
nécessité d'une parole rare et d'où la
nécessité d'une parole modeste et d'où
la nécessité d' essayer d'inverser la
vapeur
en faisant appel au sens de la
responsabiltié vaccins dont vous parlais
tout à l'heure intervient après brute
ministre qui le premier a essayé de me
persuader qu'il fallait absolument que
nous fassions effectué ses lunettes et
que monsieur vaccin aujourd'hui monsieur
fisher fischer tavira la foulée pour
nous expliquer boulot là là on sait pas
il faut être très prudent à queue il
faudrait et comme ce n'est pas du tout
ce que tout ça ça va donner et qu'il est
censé être le principal avocat de cette
affaire ça laisse rêveur
on parlait des questions également
composé sur le figaro alors celle du
jour il ya l'emportent sur le vide mais
pas en france c'est sur la grande
bretagne est ce qu est la raison de
démarrer la vaccination dès maintenant
et vous pouvez continuer à voter vous
avez été déjà très nombreux à voter en
répondant oui c'est par la reine et le
quasi centenaire du d'edimbourg ils sont
prévues m'enfin là c'est les premières
images qu'on a eu en ce moment c'était
effectivement des gens qui étaient
octogénaire mais voilà la première
personne qui a été vaccinée ce matin
devant les caméras et devant les
appareils photos
on compatit faire au compatis à son sort
et d'avoir autant de caméras d'objectifs
braqués sur elle
mais pour l'instant ils ne sont pas
encore prêts ils sont prévues mais ils
n'ont pas encore été testé que vacciner
week en revanche ce fameux vaccin qui
est testée au royaume-uni l'alvac
visière faiza c'est absolument évident
qu'il va être qu'on va l'utiliser nous
donc personne n'imagine une seconde
qu'on veut dire non non non ne veut pas
trop donc que ce soit quinze jours plus
tôt trois semaines plus tôt de toute
façon ce sera le même vaccin dans trois
semaines ou dans un mois qu'on utilisera
alors avec les mêmes interrogations mais
le fait d'attendre trois semaines ne le
rend pas plus sûres
on aura quelques effets dieu bénisse
l'angleterre quand même ça ça avant
l'été est court terme on est assez
tranquille c'est vrai que sa rigueur
justement en attendant donc la question
quand vous posez vous pouvez continuer à
y répondre
faut-il revoir le seuil de 5 mille
nouveaux cas par jour fixé par le
gouvernement pour le déconfinement
questions posées sur youtube et sur
twitter et dans les deux cas vous êtes
une large majorité à répondre oui il ya
une autre question qu'on pose sur
twitter et youtube c'est croyez-vous à
l'utilité du beauvau de la sécurité
proposée par emmanuel macron alors cette
proposition figure en fait dans une
lettre écrite par le président de la
république aux patrons d'unités fo sgp
police yves lefebvre à l'intérieur donc
se trouve cette proposition d'organiser
l'équivalent d'un grenelle ou d'un ségur
de la police emmanuel macron répondait
ainsi à la colère de syndicats après les
propos qu'il a tenus sur brut vendredi
dernier concernant les contrôles au
faciès le président veut revenir
notamment cette occasion sur les sept
chantiers de la réforme qui a présenté
une mise de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
fin novembre la formation l'encadrement
les moyens la fameuse captations vidéos
des interventions
les inspections et également la lutte
contre les discriminations et le rapport
aux médias avant d'avoir votre avis de
d'en débattre avec alexis et philippe
je vous propose d'écouter celui du maire
lr d'orléans serge grouard
enfin les problèmes on les connaît les
solutions les connaît y a pas besoin n'y
a pas besoin de faire ça il ya besoin
juste d'agir bon sens quand est ce que
dans ce pays on va agir
les responsables politiques sont là pour
agir ils sont pas là pour convoquer des
bobos de je-ne-sais-quoi ça n'a aucun
sens c'est une manière de se défausser
de la responsabilité politique qui
devient insupportable
c'est une manière de se défausser
écoutez en traversant votre rédaction
pour venir jusqu'aux studios
je suis frappé par la jeunesse vos
collaborateurs si vos lecteurs ont le
même âge il faut leur rappeler que
grenelle ça vient du grenelle qui a eu
lieu en mai 68 l'époque pompidou chirac
krasucki
edmond maire et quelques autres et que
ce grenelle a eu des effets immédiats
ça s'est tout de suite traduit par une
augmentation du smic par un changement
dans les vacances par un changement dans
l'action syndicale à l'intérieur des
entreprises etc
depuis les grenelles fonds
singulièrement penser à la phrase de
clemenceau si vous voulez enterrer un
problème nommé une commission là on a un
grain fait une confidence et le début de
la chronique directement dans le figaro
magazine
en fin de week-end il n'y a pas que les
grands c'est sûr qu'ils seront sur ce
sujet là cela est donc la chronique qui
fait figaro eh bien je la dirai avec
attention et ouellet et demandera des
droits est alors beauvau vaches cochons
couvées ségur tout ce que vous voulez
c'est il me semble quand même que à
l'orangé lui la proposition donc reprise
par monsieur darmana il y aura donc
cette chantier
7 c'est comme grenelle c'est magique
sept samouraïs sept mercenaires 7,5 rohm
ans etc etc
sept péchés capitaux et les cet apôtre
+5 ils étaient 12 il ya la formation
l'encadrement les moyens les captations
vidéo
l'inspection les effectifs et le lien
police qu population avec le rapport aux
médias et du point de vue de la
discrimination très bien c'est à dire on
réformer tout ils vont reconnaît qu'il
faut absolument tout refaire et je me
dis mais on avait déjà reconnu qu'il
fallait tout refaire en 2017
gérard collomb avait dit qu'on allait
faire une grande concertation avec un
livre blanc et allez savoir pourquoi
samedi deux ans à ce que son successeur
monsieur castanet relance ce livre blanc
et allez savoir pourquoi ça me encore un
an avant que ce livre blanc soit publiée
en neuf ans il est tout frais il est il
est tout chaud et qu'est ce qui a dans
ce dans le livre blanc d'abord d'où
sort-il il s'orne il aimait 200
propositions
il a réuni quatre groupes de travail
avec des assises territoriales dans
chaque département il a été accueilli
avec enthousiasme
sauf peut-être par les organisations de
policiers municipaux qui trouvait qu'on
parlait pas à ces deux caisses de quoi
at-on besoin de plus de faire ça au
ministère de l'intérieur
donné je ne sais quel lancement comme on
l'a fait pour la convention le comment
ça s'appelait le grand de
l'environnement c'était un autre
grenelle enfin bon je vais vous dire je
vais faire un grenelle de mon jeu n'est
pas la rue où j'habite mais du grenelle
du 1er arrondissement où je vais réunir
tous ceux avec qui je comptais passer
noël pour confère une étude approfondie
sur des raisons qu'on a d'acheter ou de
ne pas acheter une bûche et de mettre
les grands moments ça va au delà de la
jauge craindre les recommandés par jean
castex enfin sérieusement je pars ya
aussi il devra le rapport fauvergue
comme il s'appelait fauvergue négligence
et il ya eu la peau et la proposition de
loi fauvergue le taureau enfin on a
absolument entre les mains un nombre de
cartes comme on en a pas par exemple
pour le ségur même si on en a aussi
beaucoup
donc là il ya quelque chose ou
franchement je me dis hein c'est la
communication de ces de la communication
qui fait de la fumée quand même beaucoup
et bon peut-être en lieu si les
syndicats de police se calme avec seuls
choses et ça le président de la
république va parler et ça ça change
tout car dans la maladie de la parlotte
nationale il ya un phénomène essentiel
c'est que le présent appliquée sur tous
ceux présents rappelé que la doit à
parler depuis le grand débat c'est ça
comme ça qu'on résout les crises dans ce
pays où le président l'aqmi qui parlait
par l'ipa les gens sont tellement
fatigués de crise oui arrêté rosa
maintenant on est d'accord avec tout et
donc on va nous refaire le coup car en
fait c'est uniquement pour ça c'est pour
permettre à emmanuel macron de sortir du
pétrin dans lequel il s'est fourré avec
une maestria assez borie fantin en
l'occurrence ou qui a consisté à dire on
va soutenir les policiers on est
derrière les policiers et on les
soutient tellement bien que on en fait
trop on en fait trop on a des ennuis on
a des ennuis on l'élargît rôle est là
l'article
des bêtises on les lâche on leur tape
dessus ils sont furieux ils menacent de
faire grève
ah qu'est ce qu'on fait on vers un donc
on recommence indéfiniment enfin on
al'impression on dit que les gens que
les artistes font un des taux d'intérêts
définivement la même fièvre ou que les
criminels revient sur les lieux du crime
je sais pas quel est le bon problème est
là en l'occurrence événement qu'on leur
fait à chaque fois le même coup quand il
est dans la panade il dit
comme il croit dur comme fer qu en
parlant et qu' il va réussir à emballer
la faire il se dire aurevoir réunir tout
le monde et on va refaire parler
indéfiniment et on sait très bien qu'ils
ne se retirent rien de tout ça en tout
cas rien de plus qu est ce qui était
déjà sorti parce que philippe absolument
raison ce travail là vient d'avoir lieu
ça s'appelle le livre blanc sur la
sécurité intérieure
il ya eu tous les groupes qu'on veut ya
même eu des 100 citoyens quand et renier
donc tout le tout l'appareil de de kokou
décision qu'on construction tous ces
machins qui sont à la mode
on l'a on a déjà sacrifié à tous mais on
va recommencer sauf que maintenant il y
aura le président a appelé est-ce que
justement c'est la question posée des
internautes
en filigrane de leurs commentaires
c'est que derrière cette mise en scène
pourparlers vont vous suivre
est ce que par exemple les principes qui
vainquit les recommandations qui sont
qui figure dans le livre blanc sur la
police vont être appliquées écoutez là
que c'est une façon de pas faire les
deux pas faire des réformes
pierre dac disait qu'il faut se garder
de faire des prévisions en tout cas si
elle concerne l'avenir
mais si on se réfère à l'effet que les
commissions précédentes ont eu sur
l'action gouvernementale
si on se réfère au grenelle de
l'environnement sur les décisions qui
ont été prises
il y a lieu de craindre que les
recommandations de ce livre blanc se
perdent dans les sables où beaucoup
d'entre elles qui a déjà certaines
recommandations qui ont été prises
notamment par la fameuse loi exclut
rigole global dans lequel il ya le
fameux article 24 qui énerve de temps
mais après il ya tout un tas de mesures
qu'il s'agit de l'élargissement des
compétences et la police municipale dont
vous parliez la réglementation de
sécurité privée le la protection des
majeurs que tous les feux des
fonctionnaires et des détenteurs
l'autorité publique un certain nombre de
choses le fait que
les gens qui ont agressé les détenteurs
de l'autorité publique ne puissent pas
bénéficier des mêmes remise de peine en
tout cas les déficits aux remises de
peine atténués ou paraît tout à fait
bien tout ça c'était déjà dans le livre
blanc s'était repris dans cette fois ça
va finir par être voté
après qu'est ce qui reste il reste
notamment des questions budgétaires
le fameux 1% pour la sécurité autres
fort je me souviens c'est à dire 1 %
pour la culture maintenant c'est
important pour la sécurité signaux
d'état dont ça peut être qu'on le fera
parce que toute façon je n'ai personne
n'y a plus de problème d'argent a de
l'argent on entend qu'on veut et donc
avant les élections on annoncera en tout
cas qu'on va dépenser l'argent
après on le dépense ou pas c'est une
autre affaire mais fondamentalement
c'est vrai que tout
enfin toutes les décisions il on sait
très bien ce qu'il faut faire et
on va parler on va partir il ya une
chose quand même les manifestations qui
ont eu lieu récemment et au cours
desquelles les black blocs se sont
illustrés par une brutalité violence et
est une imbécilité considérables sont
des manifestations contre cette loi
mais le problème l'un des problèmes qui
se posent à nous c'est aussi le problème
du terrorisme et dans le problème du
terrorisme
on sait on l'a vu récemment à l'occasion
des derniers attentats que le
sous-équipement le sous-effectif de la
police parce que les chantiers qui sont
indiqués l'avons de toute façon demander
du temps même s'ils sont mis avec ardeur
et rapidité en fonction pendant juste un
mot dans le terrorisme
il ya une cellule qui s'appelle la
cellule phare aux perches à ios qui est
destiné à qui les filières criminelles à
traquer la cybercriminalité cette
cellule ne comporte pas assez de
fonctionnaires et ça si on veut montrer
que on réforme tout de suite et que l'on
réforme en prenant compte en prenant en
compte sérieusement cette menace ses
phares aux qu'il nous faut et c'est un
phare aux qu'il faut donner des
effectifs est hélas il faut le faire
tout de suite pensé à leur une râpe
administrés absolument de faire
l'économie de ce fameux article 24
on invente des nouvelles incriminations
tetaria pas besoin d'inventer de
nouvelles incriminations il suffit de
mettre à son nombre de policiers qui
travaillent pour suivre les les
des délits qui sont déjà connues et et
derrière des magistrats qui se décident
vraiment a ordonné des poursuites après
qu'ils aient une paupérisation de la
police depuis des années des années on
se souvient que sarkozy lui-même avait
diminué les effectifs de police alors si
on diminue les effectifs canton démunis
pas les effectifs ont diminué les
matériels horizon des voitures pourries
ils ont des caméras on la fameuse
histoire des caméras de poitrine qui
doivent tout filmé on se rend compte
qu'elle ne filme que deux heures mais
parce qu'il est passé d'argent pour
s'acheter des caméras qui fonctionnait
bien
enfin c'est comme ça c'est vrai qu'une
espèce de quand on nous dit les
policiers ne sont pas assez formés et oh
ça nous redonne ils sont passés formés
seront à diminuer le temps de formation
on n'a pas diminué le temps de formation
pour le plaisir qu'il soit moins fort
mais on a des milliers le temps de
formation des policiers pour faire des
économies c'est toujours la même chose
donc là c'est vrai c'est vrai que si un
secteur sur lequel il faudrait de
dépenser dépenser davantage c'est
sûrement la sécurité des français et des
françaises c'est bien d'accord donc
maintenant il faut le faire mais a pas
besoin de faire le le x6m beauvau de je
sais pas quoi pour le défier des risques
qui sont faciles à faire et qui romprait
un peu avec cette traditionnelle
méfiance de l'administration l'égard des
usagers vous souvenez du tollé qu'avait
eue quand fabius avait demandé que les
fonctionnaires mettre leur nom enfin en
face de leurs guichets
là les policiers doivent mettre leur nom
il arrive rarement c'était comme les
contrats d'assurance d'en bas en
angleterre c'est dans le dos comme
maradona est quand même il ya là quelque
chose
la très difficile là on est dans le
temps additionnel mais jusqu'à vous
sauver un point qui est ce qui là aussi
c'est pas une des origines de cette de
cette mise en scène c'est que macron
veut à la fois donner des gages enfin
aux syndicats qui même en français qui
veulent de la sécurité et d'un autre
côté être quand même à l'aise sur son
pied gauche
vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui dénoncent les
violences policières qui dénonce les le
comportement de certains policiers
d'avoir des garanties par rapport à ça
et donc est ce que ça va pas justement
ce en même temps va pas blocry des 07 de
côté c'est la maladie du en même temps
on finit par se mettre tout le monde à
dos et les uns les autres mais en
matière de police c'est exactement ce
qu'on se voit qu'on vient d'assister à
une première idée on va soutenir la
police on va soutenir on va mettre en
avant l' autorité le régalien en gros le
refrain tourner à droite pour récupérer
des électeurs de droite de zsa tourne
mal on lâche tout le monde et on a
contre soi l'extrême gauche et la droite
qui dit mais finalement c'est moquer de
nos belles réussites mais les policiers
qui passe par des moments
extraordinaires mon difficile j'ai eu la
chance de voir sa soeur je crois si les
cinémas sont ouverts ça sortira juste
avant noël un film qui s'appelle bac
nord le nord c'est le nord de marseille
c'est un film de cédric ximenes avec et
la jungle si le look le bac c'est pour
la bac brigade anticriminalité sa part
d'une histoire réelle qui a valu à 18
policiers de se retrouver en
correctionnelle et de devoir quitter la
police là si on veut voir l'un des
travaux de la police on peut pas résumer
tout et si on me voir l'un des travaux
de la police sont extraordinaires
difficulté et la manière dont l'igpn
peut se conduire peut de se laisser
instrumentaliser par les voyous par les
voyous c'est à dire que cette back
réussi un coup formidable en logeant le
centre de distribution en trouvant la
drogue et l'argent de la drogue et de
l'autre côté les voyous arrive à faire
croire à faire circuler
l'accusation selon laquelle en fait les
flics compliquer la drogue pour la
vendre celle ci dit c'est pas vrai et
l'igpn arrive là dedans avec l'idée on
va casser du flic
alors on va pas le cas c'est à coup de
on les incendiant mais on va casser du
flic et c'est absolument je veux dire
c'est les questions de la police comme
toutes les autres questions doivent être
comprises dans toute leur complexité ce
film est un film qui permet d'en
apercevoir la complexité bac nord et
donc ça doit sortir donc d'ici la fin du
mois
je crois que c'est le mercredi qui
précèdent noël sur l'igpn
on peut également signaler la tribune
dans le figaro de jean-eric shuttle qui
lui s'insurge contre l'idée de rendre
cette institution indépendante et les
arguments qui le développe sont très
intéressants et donc on peut également
recommandé le nouvel esprit public
campagne de fond est la dernière
émission donc à retrouver en tête de du
site et également dans le figaro à
retrouver demain dans l'est dans les
prochaines heures parce que le pdf et
publiés incessamment sous peu et la une
qui enfin le journal qui revient
largement sur la loi sur les principes
républicains
donc la nouvelle loi sur le séparatisme
en tous les cas le nom jusqu'à présent
on se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit ici avec guillaume roquette
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi et à
très vite sur figaro life
[Musique]